je reçois maintenant robert hirsch
bonsoir bonsoir alors votre père était
diamantaire chaussée d'antin
et alors vous je sais pas si c'est vrai
cette anecdote mais l'incroyable jours
de leurs vacances à juan les pins et
beaux parents
la scène est libre pendant un instant
une scène d'un petit concert d'un petit
truc vous monter sur la scène et et vous
dansez vous perdez votre pantalon il y
avait de charlie chaplin
c'est vrai ça c'est vrai c'était à
juan-les-pins et c'était le but était
donc sur la plage et veulent à la pub
sorte depuis cessé de danse au dessus et
puis je monte comme je monte souvent
alors j'avais toujours un gâteau au
chocolat les serveurs étaient le
connaissait et puis je danse et puis en
effet j'ai perdu mais il y avait échappé
après on nous a appelés en france vous a
commencé après après guerre on disait
c'est le chaplin français sénat
c'est un surnom que c'est vrai où il a
grandi d'ailleurs je veux dire c'est
tellement pour moi c'est tellement
quelque chose de mais je sais que vous
êtes un terme enfin quand même temps
après évidemment toute votre vie vous
êtes pendant la guerre en bons à
montmorillon dans la vienne
la distorsion des prix faisiez quel âge
ben là c'est le teich devait avoir dans
les 14 15 et 7 carmen et nord après vous
apprenez vous l'êtes danseurs vous
apprenez à danser mais pas du tout et
des profs je prenais que des livres
devant la glace chez vous c'est ça et
puis avec des des jeunes filles qui
étaient réfugiés également à ce
moment-là montbrillant qu'elle faisait
dia dont ce rythme est d'accord que vous
voyez liga ne peut pas les choses avec
des voiles mais qui avait une base de
danse et donc la barre était à peu près
la même
donc ce sont elles qui petit à petit
alors il ya eu des petits gars là c'est
dans une petite ville quand même
tellement millions et puis ça a commencé
comme ça que je vais me réfugier pendant
toute la guerre là-bas cinq en cinq ans
alors vous revenez à paris on vous
propose d'entrer au quadrille de l'opéra
c'est l'époque de sas examens oui à
l'homme et à loger acceptez vous refusez
pourquoi parce que d'avoir j'ai attendu
presque trois mois avant d'avoir une
réponse mais choisit le match à vous
suivez comme des cours de théâtre a
laissé simon je ris quand j'avais
beaucoup d'amis qui faisait du théâtre
et puis au bout de
trois mois j'ai assumé un petit bout de
papier un petit bout de papier génique
vraiment un petit machin comme ça écrire
vous êtes priés de venir signer votre
engagement dans le deuxième cas c'est le
père voilà et puis à ce moment là vu le
ep la grande raison c'était le départ de
services à moins d'avoir pour moi bien
social pendant cinq ans c'était quelque
chose
oui mais si ce n'était plus pareil alors
il faut dire quand même une chose c'est
que vous aviez un drôle de caractère
dont on va vous vaincrez là vous rentrez
pensionnaires en 48 vous avez 23 ans 1
ensuite j'étais lui sociétaires à
l'unanimité ce qui est rare et vous être
et c'est la comédie française jusqu'en
73 alors je dis les rôles qu aux pieds
nus tellement enfin scapin néron
raskolnikov 12 un arlequin et vous avez
deux problèmes premier problème c'est
que vous êtes un peu les jeunes turcs à
la comédie-française vous vous heurtez
un peu la vieille garde non c'est les
jeunes turcs la viaccia a été
naturellement un surnom donné par jean
clair c'est jean meyer voilà qui était à
la base de cette espèce il ya eu quand
même un vrai renouveau avec jean-pierre
il faut le rendre cette justice à coins
de france
ça a commencé avec le dindon si vous
voulez feydeau mais c'est vraiment la
base de sa ctc meyer café ya pas fondu
notre trou rénover la true may qui a
attiré à lui des ont surtout des jeunes
que la bande à charron la nouvelle a
immédiatement il ya des gens si elle
avait bercé mon enfance recherche alors
que l'enfant terrible de 2,2 de la
comédie française parce que voulait
toujours faire d'autres trucs et la
comédie-française faut savoir quand on y
est qu'on veut faire autre chose se
demander la permission toujours et vous
ai eu plein de problèmes
et un jour vous devez remplacer jean
richard à l'amiral qui est un cabaret de
l'époque et l'on vous le refuse
carrément quoi ces réformes de gestion
oui vous jetez pas facile mais j'étais
je n'étais pas une teigne voyez souvent
mais je passais mes nuits à l'amiral
avec roger pierre jean marc thibault
magnan qui est tellement là il y avait
aussi darry cowl au piano il y avait le
feu qu'avaient son numéro 2 sous la dent
lyonnais et c'était mon nom pour avancer
votre ciel bleu oui ça vous change et
des classiques et la commune
d'être avec eux de prendre un verre avec
eux de parler avec lui
je souhaite comme un voile alors ça
c'était le premier problème donc et le
deuxième problème alors là c'est quand
même vous vous êtes heurter vous êtes
affronter querellé avec andré malraux
ministre du général de gaulle parce que
si j'ai bien compris vous vous défendiez
le fait qu'on puisse aussi jouer labiche
feydeau tout ça et pour malraux la
comédie française c'était racine
corneille
je prends un pot malraux la comédie
française c'était surtout il n'aimait
pas du tout la comédie française
oui mais pas du tout et fut un jour dans
une émission qui s'appelait téléparis
qui était présentée par jacques chavanne
se souvient vous fait une déclaration
assez anti mal on est ce que monsieur
chavanon qui était président de la rtf à
l'époque en interview interdit sa
télévision interdite d'antenne faisait
pas le droit de paraître on n'a plus
droit de citer votre nom oui pendant
quatre mois oui aujourd'hui ça existe
toujours mais c'est plus sournois oui
jahia une lumière rouge mais aujourd'hui
les listes noires aujourd'hui mais vous
vous avez vraiment été officiellement
parce que j'avais dit exactement et que
pensez vous l'auriez vous la question
sur ma loge et ben le ministre nous
avait promis d' 1 1 que ce sera fait en
douceur sans heurts et sans muflerie la
douce
on attend la muflerie ont alarmé vous
étiez vous étiez infernal alors en 74
vous quittez la comédie française est là
est ce qu'on peut dire j'aurais sharks
et que que vous avez appris qu'à un
bilan assez mitigé de votre votre
carrière après la comédie française
c'est à dire que j'ai fait je suis sorti
du français j'ai fait une pièce aux
bouffes-parisiens une pièce de jamia qu
où je me suis ramassé mais on a joué
sans fois j'ai enchaîné pas celui ci si
on tombe de cheval est monté tout de
suite faut pas un et on m'a proposé deux
pièces de victor haïm que j'aimais
énormément l'abîmé la visite avec
danièle delorme de pièce à deux
personnages mise en scène par yves
robert qu'on a joué 50 fois c'est à dire
que j'ai enchaîné bid moins sûr ouais
bid et après il ya eu l'apport de la
télévision pendant un an j'ai fait
quatre pièces quatre lots de frédéric
semaine bien sûr on sent bien vous êtes
un acteur qui vous donne est absolument
sur scène
voici ce qui a toujours fait d'ailleurs
votre votre charme et votre succès
vous dites quand la salle réagit mois
quand une salle réagit je plongerai vous
l'avez dit ya longtemps je plongerai sur
des tessons de bouteille
ça c'est extraordinaire cette espèce de
oui à tout oui c'est à dire que c'est
vrai et je vous dirai pas sur des
tessons de bouteille mais j'ai plongé à
côté d'un halte là à une émission en
direct avec my ans et je me suis cassé
le bras en v réalise de vos blessures
alors vous êtes cassé un bras à la télé
ça va être cette fois là une double
entorse dans les amants magnifiques
coups bas la tête enflée dans la machine
à écrire de cock robin offord est happé
par les termes 36 vous avez vu 36
chandelles dans ce cas pas et vous vous
êtes blessé dans 36 chandelles qui était
la fameuse émission de jean nohain et
alors le pire de tous ces deux jours
vous à laval une moustache c'est ça vous
jouiez avec georges chamarat ce que
c'est le rendez vous ça ne c'est pas
croyable oui oui le veau gras bernard
dimey et je vais moussa chez pour faire
vrai rôle de du coup collés ou une
moustache on mettait du vernis et ducret
payer butcher's de des petites choses
comme ça et un moment où tu vas me faire
taire le souhait mon père devait faire
taire ils mettaient la main sur la
figure comme il devait des fois c'est
violent la tension est un jour il m'a
fait j'ai fait est là tous mes poils mme
sont venus devant la et après vous êtes
allé sur cinq deviez crié non passer la
crise et pour de vrai parce que nous
avons tout fait pour y écouter si vous
n'êtes pas vexé quand on dit que vous
êtes un cabotin parce que ces jeunes et
non dix avaient dit dans le bulletin de
paris en 1950 c'est pas d'hier non cela
dit je suis un cabotin mais oui mais
c'est vrai oui je veux dire c'est vrai
pour moi vous voyez que vous me le dites
c'est un compliment
alors bon vous dit et on le comprend
bien vite quand quand je ne joue pas je
me sens inutile
vous dites j'ai de la chance je sais ce
qui me rend heureux et finalement vous
avez vous donné l'impression de
quelqu'un de très simple un padduc
engouement très simple
seul oui vous avez dit j'étais amoureux
une fois sept jours et puis voilà quoi
oui vous avez une vie privée de fès a
complètement oui c'est à dire c'est une
une chose que c'est pour ça que je ne
parle jamais de rien parce que je ne
vois pas ce qui pourrait intéresser qui
que ce soit si j'ai un intérêt
quelconque c'est sur scène sinon les
phrases formidable en parle d'amour vous
dit l'amour c'est un violon dingue mais
au fait pourquoi même se souvenir qu'un
grand pour lui l'essentiel c'était la
peinture oui
voilà alors dernière question qui est
pas la plus drôle en 93 effectivement
vous avez eu un infarctus mais en jouant
la folie de guitry folie et depuis vous
prenez vos petites pilules la rue basse
et avis le petit pygmée le petit plat qu
on a tous le pq oui est-ce que vous
sérieusement vous aimeriez mourir ans n
ont pas du tout pas du tout pas du tout
c'est pas un truc ça ridicule en accord
indique hull si ça m'arrive je peux pas
faire autrement c'est ce que je dis mais
d'ailleurs il ya eu des choses dont la
facture environ comme molière il a fait
mouche
mais il part en scène mais chez lui
allait pas vraiment mort en scène on a
bon d'accord il ya une malaise
elles sont là on l'a sorti de scène et
puis on en met pas du tout bon je vais
mourir tranquillement et loin et sans
commencer vous palais bourbon un conte
pas savoir à quelle heure on revient
voilà merci c'est moi qui vous remercie
heureux qu'il se balançait beaucoup
moi aussi et pour être sûr de ne rien
rater de finale andy tube abonnez vous
mettez un pouce bleus